THANK YOU SO MUCH, GRIFF.
ALL RIGHT, LET’S BRING IN NEWT
GINGRICH, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, MR.
GINGRICH.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
HEAR THOSE WORDS THAT GRIFF IS
TALKING ABOUT AND THOSE IMAGES?
>> WELL, LOOK.
I THINK YOU’RE GETTING EXACTLY
WHAT THE POLICY SUGGESTS YOU’LL
GET.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SENT A CLEAR
SIGNAL TO THE WORLD THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS OPEN FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
GALLUP ESTIMATED THERE’S
65 MILLION PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THE NUMBERS WILL KEEP GOING UP,
THE SYSTEM WILL BECOME UN
SUSTAINABLE BY SOME TIME THIS
SUMMER AND WE’LL BE BACK
WHERE WE WERE UNDER PRESIDENT
OBAMA, WE’LL HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WANDERING
AROUND, YOU’LL HAVE THE CARTELS
GETTING PAID AND THERE ARE AT
LEAST TWO CARTELS THAT HAVE
BASICALLY GIVEN UP DRUGS FOR
PEOPLE, BECAUSE THEY MAKE
MORE MONEY MOVING PEOPLE INTO
THE U.S. THAN THEY MAKE MOVING
DRUGS INTO THE U.S. , SO I THINK
THIS IS A TRACK.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM BREAKS DOWN,
AND THAT WE ARE ULTIMATELY FACED
WITH SO MANY PEOPLE YOU CAN’T
POSSIBLY MANAGE IT, THIS IS A
TERRIFIC STRATEGY, BUT WE
SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISED, WE ARE
GETTING EXACTLY WHAT THIS KIND
OF POLICY DELIVERS.
BRIAN:  YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
MEXICAN CARTELS ARE GETTING.
WE EVEN HAVE RATES.
MAYBE THERE’S A RATE CARD OUT
THERE.
U.S. BORDER PATROL SAYS THAT IF
YOU BRING ONE PERSON ACROSS, AT
$3,250, AFRICAN TRAVELERS,
$20,000, ASIANS WILL PAY MORE,
THE EVALUATION SAID THERE WILL
BE SIGNIFICANT INFLUX OF
MIGRANTS, THEY EXPECT CARIBBEANS
, ASIANS AND MIDDLE
EASTERS TO BE THERE IN THE
SPRING AND THE SUMMER AND
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT JOE BIDEN
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HOW ABOUT WHO SAID THIS TO
REUTERS THEY SEE HIM, MEANING
BIDEN, AS THE MIGRANT PRESIDENT
SO MANY FEEL THEY ARE GOING TO
REACH THE UNITED STATES, MEXICO
SAYS THIS IS A CRISIS.
THEY WANT IT ADDRESSED.
HOW CAN HE WALK AWAY FROM THIS
AND PRETEND THAT IT’S NOT A
FIVE ALARM FIRE?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU’RE DEALING
WITH THE PRESIDENT WHO FORGETS
THE NAME OF HIS SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE AND FORGETS THE NAME OF
THE PENTAGON, HE COULD PROBABLY,
I DON’T KNOW THAT HE WALKS AWAY
BUT PROBABLY SIT AWAY FOREVER.
WHY WOULD ANY OF THIS AFFECT HIM
HE WILL SAY OH, I GUESS THAT’S
PROBABLY THE PROBLEM, AND I
THINK THAT WE REALLY
UNDERESTIMATE THE DEGREE TO
WHICH HE’S DETACHED FROM REALITY
AND THE DEGREE TO WHICH PEOPLE
WILL LATER ON LOOK BACK AND SAY
GOSH, THERE WERE TERRIBLE
CONSEQUENCES, WHY DIDN’T WE KNOW
BETTER?
WELL WE DID KNOW BETTER BUT WE
ADOPTED A POLICY DELIBERATELY
THAT SENDS A SIGNAL.
YOU KNOW, EVERYWHERE IN THE
WORLD, WHETHER THEY’RE
WATCHING FOX & FRIENDS, WHETHER
THEY’RE JUST TALKING TO THEMSELF
, PEOPLE GOSSIP, AND
THEY LEARN AND EVERYWHERE IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW THE SIGNALS
OUT THAT THE U.S. IS A WELCOME
MATT, THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO COME STAY, AND
THE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES IN
AMERICA, DESPITE EVERYTHING, ARE
STILL SO MUCH BETTER THAN IN
MOST OF THE WORLD.
YOU CAN’T BLAME A FATHER OR  A
MOTHER WHO WANTS THEIR CHILD TO
GROW UP HERE, RATHER THAN IN
POVERTY, BUT YOU CAN BLAME THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT FOR NOT
BEING HONEST ABOUT THE COST.
THIS IS GOING TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE AND
IT’S GOING TO SHAKE I THINK THE
FABRIC OF AMERICAL SOCIETY,
AND I GUESS, MY GUESS IS THAT IN
FOUR YEARS OF THE HARRIS-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION YOU’RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY SEE ENORMOUS INFLUX,
PROBABLY IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
SIX TO 15 MILLION PEOPLE.
STRATEGIST SPEAKING
STEVE: SPEAKING OF COSTLY
YESTERDAY THE HOUSE PASSED THE
$1.9 TRILLION RELIEF BILL
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO BE SIGNING IT TOMORROW,
THERE WILL BE A BIG CELEBRATION,
AND THINGS LIKE THAT, BUT YOU
KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED TO THE UNITY
WE HEARD JOE BIDEN TALK ABOUT I
WANT EVERYBODY TO BE TOGETHER,
WE’RE GOING TO GO FORWARD, WE’RE
NOT GOING TO DO ALL THAT PARTY
LINE STUFF.
SO FAR, EVERYTHING THEY’VE DONE,
MR. SPEAKER, IS PARTY LINE, AND
IT’S NOT LIKE JOE BIDEN IS
RUNNING THE PARTY.
IT’S NANCY AND CHUCK ARE TELLING
JOE WHAT TO DO.
>> WELL AND THEN I THINK KAMALA
HARRIS.
I REALLY DO THINK THIS IS
BECOMING THE HARRIS-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU CAN TELL
THAT EVERY TIME YOU SEE HIM IN
PUBLIC.
WHY WOULD YOU THINK THAT HE’S
DRAMATICALLY BETTER IN PRIVATE
THAN HE IS WHEN HE CAN’T TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS IN PUBLIC?
HE CAN’T REMEMBER WHAT HE’S
TALKING ABOUT.
HE CAN’T REMEMBER HIS OWN
NOMINEES.
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT HE’S A
VERY MINOR FORCE INSIDE THAT
BUILDING AND THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS INCREASINGLY RUN BY
HARRIS, PELOSI, AND SCHUMER, AND
OF COURSE, LOOK, THESE ARE HARD
LINE LIBERALS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT THINK THAT
IT’S FINE THAT WALMART OR
RATHER, THAT A MAJOR DRUG STORE
COMPANY IS CLOSING EVERY SINGLE
DRUG STORE IN SAN FRANCISCO
BECAUSE THEY WILL NO LONGER
PROSECUTE PETTY THEFT AND PEOPLE
HAVE LEARNED YOU CAN STEAL UP TO
$950 AND COME BACK A COUPLE
HOURS LATER AND STEAL ANOTHER
$950, SO YOU LITERALLY ARE
WATCHING THE COLLAPSE OF WHAT
YOU AND I THOUGHT OF AS
CIVILIZATION.
THAT’S THE WORLD OF PELOSI AND
SCHUMER AND HARRIS, AND THEY’RE
HAPPY TO GIVE IT TO THE REST OF
US.
AINSLEY: SO THERE IS A HEADLINE
THIS MORNING ABOUT A NEW YORK
CITY SCHOOL.
IT’S DOWNTOWN, IT’S IN NOHO,
WHICH IS NOLITA AND SOHO AREA
AND IT’S CALLED GRACE CHURCH
SCHOOL AND PARENTS SPEND $57,000
A YEAR YEAR TO SEND THEIR KIDS
HERE.
STEVE: WHAT?
AINSLEY: THEY SENT OUT A 12-PAGE
MEMO TO ALL OF THE STUDENTS AND
TO THE PARENTS SAYING YOU DON’T
NEED TO SAY CERTAIN WORDS AT
HOME, INCLUDING MOM AND DAD,
THEY NOW WANT YOU TO SAY GROWN-
UPS, FOLKS, FAMILY, OR
GUARDIANS.
THEY SAY DON’T ASK ANYONE WHERE
YOU’RE FROM.
YOU NEED TO SAY WATT IS YOUR
CULTURAL OR  ETHNIC BACKGROUND.
THEY DON’T WANT YOU TO SAY MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY HAPPY
HOLIDAYS OR  HAVE A GREAT BREAK
INSTEAD OF BOYS AND GIRLS, GUYS,
LADY, AND GENTLEMEN, YOU NEED TO
SAY PEOPLE, FOLKS, FRIENDS,
READERS, OR  MATHEMATICIANS.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, LOOK.
NOBODY HAS NOTICED IT YET BUT
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS UNANIMOUSLY
VOTED IN THE RULES TO ELIMINATE
MOTHER, FATHER, BROTHER, SISTER,
THEY TOOK OUT 29 GENDER-SPECIFIC
NAMES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE THINGS
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE YOU’RE
DEALING, FOR EXAMPLE, WITH A
BILL WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY THE
GAY AND TRANSEXUAL SUPREMACY
ACT WHICH BASICALLY SAYS YOU CAN
PRACTICE YOUR RELIGION AS LONG
AS YOU DON’T OFFEND ANYBODY BUT
IT’LL BE ILLEGAL IF YOU OFFEND
ANYBODY, AND I THINK WE ARE SEE
ING A TREMENDOUS ASSAULT ON
THE WHOLE NOTION OF WHETHER
THERE ARE MALES AND FEMALES.
YOU HAD THE PRESIDENT SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT ALLOWS
TRAN SEXUAL MALES TO COMPETE AS
THOUGH THEY’RE FEMALES WHICH
WE KNOW GUARANTEES THE END OF
WOMEN’S SPORTS, BECAUSE IF YOU
GROW UP THROUGH YOUR TEENAGE
YEARS MALES SIMPLY ARE GOING TO
WIN MOST OF THE CONTESTS.
WE’RE IN A PERIOD WHERE THE
WEIDEREST PEOPLE, AND I’LL
GET IN TROUBLE FOR SAYING IT BUT
I’M OLD ENOUGH THAT I GREW UP IN
A DIFFERENT WORLD.
I GREW UP IN A WORLD WHERE WE
RECOGNIZE THERE REALLY WERE
MOTHER AND FATHER AND WE THOUGHT
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO HAVE A
MOTHER AND A FATHER.
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO
RECOGNIZE BOYS AND GIRLS.
YOU KNOW, IN CALIFORNIA, THERE’S
A BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WOULD MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR A
DEPARTMENT STORE TO HAVE A BOYS
SECTION AND A GIRL’S SECTION.
THIS IS A MADNESS, I RECENTLY
DID A PODCAST WITH SAD GAD AND
HE’S AMAZING BECAUSE HE SAYS
BASICALLY, WE NOW HAVE PARASITES
IN OUR BRAIN THAT ARE CULTURAL
PARASITES, AND THAT PEOPLE JUST
LITERALLY ARE CRAZY AND I THINK
YOU’RE SEEING AN EXAMPLE OF THE
CRAZINESS
BRIAN:  LET’S MOVE ON.
WE CAN GO ON THIS FOREVER BUT
SADLY IT’S COMING FROM AMERICA
AND IT’S INFECTING THE WORLD.
IT’S USUALLY THE OPPOSITE AND
I’M EMBARRASSED BY IT.
MEANWHILE, I’M NOT EMBARRASSED
ABOUT THIS.
A FOUR-PART LOOK ON FOX NATION
ABOUT RUSH LIMBAUGH.
WHERE HE CAME FROM, THE IMPACT
HE MADE AND WHILE HE’LL CONTINUE
TO RESONATE IN THE FUTURE.
YOU SAW IT UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL
YOUR RISE MIMICKED HIS RISE.
HERE YOU ARE, COMMENTING ON THE
RUSH LIMBAUGH YOU KNEW.
>> LET ME TRACK MY KNOWLEDGE.
I’M BECOMING AWARE OF NEWT
GINGRICH FOR YOU.
IT’S YOUR EARLY 80S AND THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
JUST CREAMING REAGAN, EVERY DAY.
PERSONALLY, HIS IDEAS, HIS
POLICIES, AND I’D GO HOME WHEN I
HAD A NIGHT FREE AND WATCH CSPAN
, AND THERE WAS THIS
GUY DOING SPECIAL ORDERS.
HE AND A COUPLE OF HIS
ASSOCIATES WERE SPEAKING TO AN
EMPTY HOUSE CHAMBER BUT AS
LONG AS SOMEBODY WAS IN THERE
SPEAKING, CSPAN HAD TO COVER IT
AND THIS GUY WAS RONALD REAGAN
JR..
BRIAN:  IT WAS NEWT GINGRICH, I
HAD IT BACKWARDS, NEWT.
DID YOU KNOW THAT RUSH WAS OUT
THERE AND SUPPORTING YOU?
>> WELL, LOOK, RUSH WENT
NATIONAL IN 1988.
HE WAS A STRONG ALLIE OF OURS,
HE WAS A BIG FACTOR IN OUR
VICTORY IN 1994 WITH THE
CONTRACT WITH AMERICA.
HE AND REAGAN HAD AN ABILITY TO
USE COMMON LANGUAGE SO THE
AVERAGE PERSON COULD
UNDERSTAND IT TO DESCRIBE THINGS
THAT WERE SO BLATANTLY TRUE THAT
THEY JUST, THEY BOTH SORT OF RAN
OVER THEIR OPPONENTS WITH THE
SHEAR LOGIC OF THEIR
LANGUAGE, AND RUSH WAS A MAJOR
FORCE.
I’D SAY PRIOR TO THE RISE OF FOX
NEWS, HE WAS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT POPULOUS CONSERVATIVE
FORCE IN THE COUNTRY, AND WE ARE
A DIFFERENT COUNTRY, A BETTER
COUNTRY, BECAUSE OF RUSH
LIMBAUGH.
STEVE: YOU KNOW HE WAS SUCH A
GOOD EXPLAINER.
HE WAS A GREAT ENTERTAINER AND A
BROADCASTER BUT HE WOULD GO INTO
WHAT OTHER BROADCASTERS WOULD
NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS TALK
ABOUT ON THE RADIO, AND HE’D
TALK ABOUT IT FOR AN HOUR AND BY
THE END IT’S LIKE OH, THAT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE.
WELL I GOT A QUESTION FOR YOU,
NEWT.
WHO TAKES OVER FOR HIM?
BECAUSE HE IS LEAVING A GIGANTIC
VOID IN THE WORLD OF
BROADCASTING.
>> WELL I THINK MARK STEIN
PROBABLY HAS THE
INSIDE TRACK AS A REALLY
INTERESTING INTELECTUAL WHOSE
ALSO VERY FUNNY AND VERY CAPABLE
OF DOING IT AND HE’S BEEN DOING
RUSH’S SHOW FOR A GOOD BIT AND
AS RUSH WAS TAKING CHEMOTHERAPY
AND I CERTAINLY THINK HE’S A
POSSIBILITY.
NOBODY IS GOING TO REPLACE RUSH.
I MEAN, RUSH WAS A UNIQUE PERSON
, PROBABLY THE PERSON
WHOSE COME CLOSEST TO REPLACE
HIM, IS SHAWN HANNITY.
IF YOU LOOK, HE DOES THREE HOURS
OF RADIO A DAY AND THEN AN HOUR
OF TELEVISION AT NIGHT.
HE HAS A HUGE AUDIENCE, BUT EVEN
SHAWN WOULD SAY THAT RUSH HAD A,
HE HAD A UNIQUE SET OF ABILITIES
YOU WERE EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE UNDERSTOOD HE HAD TO
ENTERTAIN YOU TO GET YOU TO STAY
LISTENING LONG ENOUGH THAT HE
CO-ED YOU INDICATE YOU, AND AS A
RESULT, HE HAD A HUGE AUDIENCE,
AND HE WAS GENUINELY FUNNY.
THERE AREN’T MANY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE AS GOOD A SENSE OF HUMOR AS
RUSH DID.
REAGAN WAS ANOTHER ONE, BUT RUSH
WAS PROBABLY FUNNIER THAN REAGAN
AND WORKED AT BEING FUNNY.
UNDERSTOOD THAT HIS REAL POWER
WAS YOU LIKED LISTENING TO HIM,
NOT JUST YOU LEARNED, BUT YOU
LIKED, YOU HAD A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP AND HE HAD A
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH ABOUT
23 MILLION PEOPLE, SO IT’S A
REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT.
AINSLEY: YEAH, THEY WERE ALL SO
SAD, IT WAS A SAD DAY WHEN HE